sunday night about books begins at 9 p.m
with grace pally followed by geraldine
norman at 10 20.
now joe krause discusses a book he's
co-written called an accidental
anarchist it tells the story of the
death of lazarus avrebuck a russian
immigrant in 1908 in chicago and what
his killing says about law order and
civil rights in early 20th century
america
joe crouse is a phd candidate at
northwestern university and the editor
of the chicago jewish history journal he
spoke at 57th street books in chicago
tonight we're very pleased to welcome
joe krauss co-author of the book an
accidental anarchist
in 1908 a 19 year old jewish immigrant
traveled across chicago to the to the
luxurious home of police chief george
shippy
minutes after knocking on the door the
immigrant lazarus averbuck was dead shot
six times by the police chief
the resulting controversy and differing
accounts of the death won the attention
of the entire country and involved
figures ranging from jane addams to emma
goldman
in the accidental anarchist authors joe
krause and walter roth take the first
complete look at the incident
drawing on a wide range of sources
not to solve the case but to reveal the
deep-seated issues on the role of the
media and the fear of rising immigration
that fueled the fire surrounding the
trial
joe krause is editor of chicago jewish
history the journal of the chicago
jewish historical society
mr krauss is a ph.d candidate in
american literature at northwestern
university
and he has been an instructor at several
chicago colleges and universities
including northwestern
roosevelt university columbia college
and the spurtus institute of jewish
studies
his work has appeared in american
scholar the prohibition era times in
chicago jewish history
mr krauss is a graduate of both the
university of michigan and new york's
columbia university
due to a death in the family his
co-author walter roth is not able to be
with us tonight
we are pleased that mr krause agrees to
go solo so please welcome show cross
thank you solve and uh
thank all of you for coming um i do want
to i'm very excited to be here and look
forward to talking about i did want to
start just on the somber note of
echoing that walter roth wanted to be
here very much
and would have been here except for
a death in his family so
what i want to do today is essentially
try to conduct a dialogue in one voice
if that makes any sense because i think
that's the process that went into uh
putting this book together so i will try
to uh try to echo his voice and echo his
concerns in the sort of things that
we've had to say about this book um in
the various opportunities we've had to
talk about it
um
uh my hope for what we will do um in
this discussion
is that i will say a few minutes i speak
for a few minutes about uh the book how
we came to do it
um some of the questions that i see
still being unanswered and then i hope
um you'll have some questions either
about the things that um uh that you've
heard me say or things that you know
already from having read the book or
some of the publicity or just just seen
the the particular photograph
it's been almost 90 years to the day
since lazarus averbach
left his west side
maxwell street area jewish
ghetto area went to the home of the
chief of police of chicago george shippy
he knocked on shippy's door and uh we
don't know why we speculate about it for
different reasons especially speculate
about different reasons for that in the
book
knocked down the door
uh he was admitted
and within five minutes he was shot dead
seven times
and that's a mystery
still unsolved
we have a couple thoughts about what
might have happened with that
but uh
it seemed to be a remarkable opportunity
to take a look at a case for the
specific case
and then an instance that made clear a
lot of the tensions a lot of the issues
that were running through
through chicago
walter usually starts this part because
this book starts with walter and starts
with um an accidental discovery on
walter's part the accidental history to
an accidental anarchist
researching another unrelated subject
he came upon a headline in the chicago
paper
talking about assassin jewish assassin
dead just screaming headlines
i don't know which particular paper it
was because virtually every paper in
chicago ran headlines like that for at
least a week and for an entire month it
was all-consuming
this was 1908
um all consuming in the way uh the
president's current crisis is now i
suppose just every newspaper every
headline
and then a month later it vanished
um and walter was stunned when he'd come
upon this and he started following up he
traced two or three different newspapers
for several days what was this what was
happening
um and was all the more stunned to find
that this was
um a a young jewish boy a russian jewish
immigrant and the more he read
i mean i don't want to put too many
words in his mouth but the more he read
i think the more a sense he got that
there'd been a grave injustice
done to this young man
if nothing else he was being he was
accused of being an anarchist
uh that when the chief of police was
immediately his initial statement after
this encounter was
this young boy was an assassin
he'd come to kill me
ergo he was an anarchist as well
i shot in self-defense after he had
attacked uh not just me but also my son
and my bodyguard
uh we like to call we call that the
official story
and that really was the the way the
story remained although i would like to
have a chance to talk about some of the
ways that story came to be assaulted but
as walter looked at that it seemed to
him that there was a grave injustice at
the very least
even if we didn't know why this young
boy had gone to the home of the chief on
that day um
it seemed clear he hadn't gone there
he seemed clear at least he didn't have
the background of a hostile assassin we
were skeptical about whether he was any
kind of an assassin at all
so i think walter began digging and
probing
uncovering remarkable documents
there there
is some data relating to the coroner's
inquest of the of the case
he was able to
arrange for translations from some of
the original yiddish newspapers
so we had access we also had access to
harold ikky's heraldicky senior
he was
central to this case his papers were
sealed for 25 years after his death so
we were some of the first people to have
the opportunity to work with those
papers
to go through all this material
and try to find some way of arguing this
is i think walter's agenda that this is
a man a young man whose story has never
had never been told
and who has been maligned by history as
much as history remembers him at all it
remembers him as an anarchist as an
assassin
somewhere in there walter came to me and
he said i found all of this material
and he brought a very large box of
material
not just raw material i mean there were
there were you know things right out of
the newspapers but also material he had
digested he had transcribed he had put
into various um interesting ways of
telling this story it's a complicated
story that doubles back on itself um and
he said i've got all this material
let's boil it down
and so that's where i came in in an
effort to to boil this down and while i
was drawn into lazarus averbach's story
and
and found myself wanting to know more
about him who he was and why he was
there i was also drawn into what i
consider the larger
crisis here the larger conflict and that
is that it wasn't just an individual boy
who happened to come from one place to
another place in the city of chicago it
was somebody from
a ghetto
somebody without money somebody without
access to
what i would call the mainstream culture
of chicago certainly the powerful um
government of government or or
industrial power of chicago
colliding literally and violently
with someone who does represent that
power structure someone who is the chief
of police of the city of chicago
and it occurred to me that that
story was another story that we might
tell
and so what i hope has happened in this
book is that it really is a fusion of
those two agendas that they're not ones
that necessarily contradict each other
but i hope in fact enrich them
so that what we have is a story of a
young man
and a story of a city at the same time
both of which call for often for
speculation but both of which i hope
ask for a lot of sympathy for a world of
chicago that's that's that's fairly far
distant
i'll pause just a moment to see if if i
if anybody has questions to start with
i remember
reading
a report about this around 10 years ago
about this age
in chicago what why why would he go to
the police chief
in the first place the police
chief
police chief of chicago this russian
jewish immigrant i was told that in
russia under cyrus russia before he
could even leave town
he could he has to go to the russian
chief of police and tell him my minister
and i want to leave i'm telling you
ahead of time so you won't come after me
so that was not the reasoning why he
went to the police chief
there there's certainly people who came
to feel this way again the if one
central mystery here is why would
somebody like lazarus averbach go so far
away
um
to a place he seemed to have no business
being
um and and one of the one of the common
theories it's one that uh a number of
people put forward in here uh averbach's
own sister among others um is that is
that he was looking for what what they
call a writ of proteccia
a
note certifying his good conduct so that
he was free to leave the city of chicago
and go to another city and it would have
to be signed by the chief of police
there are certainly people who took that
seriously and um
and i think there's reason to weigh that
as one possible reason that he was there
it wasn't it was the custom in russia
and that begs a further question how
could it be that someone who had been in
this country for only three months but
still was in this country for three
months living with a sister who'd been
here for two years his only relative in
this country how could he be that
misinformed if indeed that was what was
going on
and
um it speaks again to just these vast
cultural differences even if he had a
sense that he needed something like this
why not go to the chief of police
to the rather the police station rather
than to the chief's home why go to what
must have been considerably more trouble
to go to a private residence on the
north side um than to try to go to a
local police station
the chief no or the person
we we can only speculate um my my
suspicion is
lazarus aberbach
lazarus you asked the question is
whether lazarus averbach was fearing for
his life
um it's hard for me to imagine why he
would have been fearing for his life in
this country
one of the ironies of course is that he
had to flee pogroms in russia
he and his family were uprooted when he
was a young boy he had to uh he had to
leave his home
found a new home in in central europe
and then
followed his sister over here to work
to try to work and make a living in
the united states
so we have this this
obvious and dark irony of somebody
fleeing oppression fleeing police
oppression in in many respects only to
be murdered here in the city
so it wasn't the climate in chicago
again
that year he prides it out the
anti-labor
uh
screaming anarchist against these labor
unions anarchism
and they're all foreigners
they're all eastern european russian
jews you know and this is a young jew
coming to uh
yeah that's that's very good i mean we
can only speculate about we can begin to
recreate the kind of anti-immigrant
hysteria and anti-immigrant um
fervor that would have been present in
in chicago of the time
the word anarchist is a powerful word in
chicago most of all because chicago has
the legacy of the haymarket uh riots
um
as is as is um
uh
for certainly first certainly for the
haymarket riots which is which is sort
of resonating in chicago at that very
moment and one of the sub stories within
an accidental anarchist is that the
leading anarchist in chicago the leading
anarchist in the country if not the
world was emma goldman at that time and
emma goldman was scheduled to speak in
chicago
and
there's some suspicion that rather than
overbox fearing for his life that it was
shippy who feared for his life in part
because he had said emma goldman will
not speak here
and there are some who speculate that
the reason young auverbach went to
shippy's home was to say i think that
she ought to speak
although there's no evidence he had any
um ongoing relationship with anarchist
thinking or individuals involved in what
i like to call the oxymoron of organized
anarchy
another reason that shippy may well have
feared for his life is the other side of
that you mentioned that that anarchists
were typically anarchist itself was a
scare word
i'm convinced that anarchist is often
a label a more frightening label and one
that puts a sharper edge on
immigrant in general
the labor movement is a part of that
that often being
tarred or tainted as as being uh
anarchist and inflected although um
whether they actually were
is is certainly um
up up for grabs uh
you had you had a um
a depression of sorts there were you had
periodic depressions um leading up to
the great depression um uh and and there
was a larger ones in the 1880s but 1908
saw a pretty serious depression so there
was a lot of unemployment uh one of
chicago's most interesting and colorful
characters ben reitman i don't know if
any of you have heard the name
ben reitman led
just a month before this incident
something called the march of the
unemployed he was the self-appointed
king of the hobos of chicago
and what he'd done with the march of the
unemployed was try to gather unemployed
workers march them through the city as a
protest to working conditions um
uh
um and the the march was broken up
there were some claims that averbach had
been part of the march of the unemployed
which would have been odd in fact
because in fact was employed as an egg
crater of all unlikely jobs um but um
reitman himself denied ever having seen
he was called in to identify the body
i mentioned emma goldman's coming too
one of the one of the
interesting the the love plot the love
subplot of the book is that um
uh when emma goldman came to chicago she
was determined to speak
just as much as if the murder had never
taken place but because of the murder
not so much shippy who oddly enough
falls out of the picture but his acting
replacement
shuttler hermann shutler
said no way will you be able to speak so
there's this interesting
shuttlerist is telling emma goldman she
can't speak in an effort to find a place
where she could speak she meets up with
ben reitman
and they do fall in love and have a
tempestuous affair that lasts for 10
years
so among the interesting
perspectives on the
averbach case
are
is information both from both of their
memoirs and biographies that have been
written about them
i mentioned though that while we have
anarchist as a kind of
scare word there really are some
anarchists
like emma goldman
um
but i think that the label anarchist
often came to serve as as the the horror
mask the fear mask that would go on the
face of the immigrant
um
ironically the haymarket riot in chicago
was um
supposed to have been led this is in the
uh 1880s was supposed to have been led
by with the people who were found guilty
of having led it or fomenting what
became known as the riot were
mostly english and german speakers let
us say were west europeans
i think if you have to go back to the
assassination of mckinley
in 1901 which was done by um cholgovich
i i butchered the pronunciation of the
name done by an east european before i
think you start seeing a radical shift
in what we think the anarchist looks
like
by the time of 1908 the anarchist is a
very shady guy
the large bushy eyebrows
sallow skin
the hat stoop shouldered
uh
and a big bomb
the big bomb within with the with the
fuse coming out of it
yes it is a cartoon in one in more than
one newspaper but what's odd is the
power of that image moving beyond
the cartoon into a real um
a real boogie figure for
these people who simply happen to be
different from us
um
so
anarchist often becomes associated with
immigrant in this period and so
there's there's originally no evidence
that this averbach is an anarchist
the fact that he is an assassin
the fact that he is an immigrant and
originally the initial reports think he
might have been
an italian
or um
i forget i forget the other nationality
armenian an italian and armenian which
is to say in any case different
eventually they determine they determine
within just a couple of hours that he
that he's in fact jewish although it
takes him a little longer to identify
his name
but those two factors that he is an
assassin
and that he's foreign are enough to tell
you he's an anarchist
coming together like that um just as a
footnote something that begins or you
know foot is probably not the proper
part of the body to refer to uh an
incident that we find at the beginning
of this book is in the tribune the day
before this killing
there was an article talking as a
sidebar related to an incident where a
young woman had her nose broken and was
suing for damages dr bessie andrus suing
for damages
and she insisted she deserved
exceptionally high damages because her
nose was a particularly valuable kind of
nose
it was a roman nose
so what the tribune ran was a chart
chronicling the noses of chicago
talking about what the different kinds
of noses were implying monetary value
and conveniently enough for our purposes
they actually tell you chief shippy's
nose
what kind of nose it is how sort of
strong and robust you know i don't know
how the nose tells you that he's six
foot tall with broad shoulders
um
but uh they also have the hebrew nose
which is kind of beady um
uh
cunning intelligence it says interested
in looking out for number one
um
that's the state of of the immigrant
at that period that's the state of these
people who are um
in but not of chicago or if they are of
chicago they are of a chicago that is
not the chicago of which george shippy
is one representative
um
and so what we have then is these
two i call them forces i don't know if
they are forces they're people they
don't express themselves as forces
they're probably not conscious of
themselves as forces the people who live
in a city
and have rare intercourse with each
other seldom see each other and when
they do
necessarily respond to each other um as
stereotypes
um i can pause for a moment i know that
i can ramble on and on i don't know if i
have left out something particularly
obvious or if if um have
prompted any other
the uh the questions in chicago the
atmosphere of anti-foreign immigrants
there was a lot of immigrants
and uh
the newspapers reflected that probably
and wasn't this the uh well it was the
end of it was 19th century was was all
racism you know they had they had the
struggle against slavery and
colonialism and anti-foreign and uh
you know this was uh yeah i think it's
it's easy to recognize in retrospect how
um in some sense i mean ironically we've
almost gone through a a succession of
i'll go back to the term boogie figures
succession of characters who are not us
who um remind us of what we are
and constitute a remainder
of those people who we have not included
in in our society you can go back to the
native american you can go back to the
african-american you can go to the irish
to the jews to the italians and you can
keep going right on past our particular
moment here to um often hispanics it's
it's a chronicle that we're all ashamed
of um i i
i know that
um
but
as important as i think that recognition
is i think it also becomes
something we lose
that loses a lot of value unless we can
go back to the particular dynamics of a
given moment
and and that's one of the things i hope
we're able to accomplish in in our book
in an accidental anarchist
is to go back to what the the specific
tensions were that this young boy who
happened to be jewish but could as
readily have been from the perspective
of george ship he could as readily have
been armenian or italian
what kind of
knee-jerk hatreds come out of that at
that particular moment at that
particular instant
1908 is not the same as 1920
it's a very different moment um it's
particularly i mean it's unfortunate of
course lazarus averbach doesn't live to
see 1920 but one can assume the 31 year
old lazarus averbach of 1920 would have
been a very different
from
the man of 1908 the the boy of 1908
um one thing one way i've tried to
describe this story
is
as a story that shaped like i mean you
can take your pick either a bagel or a
doughnut
i figure since since it is a jewish
story i figured we should go with the
bagel
um but in either case it's a story
where we know a lot about the edges but
we don't know what happened in the
middle there's the hole in the middle
to me that middle is the story that um
that solve a told you that i told you
that a young boy went somewhere for some
strange reason and was killed and we
don't know why
we guess about it and speculated about
it the writ of proteccia is one one
factor that goes into that i i
i can talk to if anyone's interested in
some of the other possibilities that are
in there but what i found fascinating
about this story and one reason i think
that
um
sort of my my own agenda in the
conversation that walter and i had made
some sense to me as i was imagining it
is that you had a number of people
responding to this incident so although
we don't know what the incident was we
know how people reacted to it
and what's fascinating to me and this
goes back to the point about the the
particular the particular
moment in which this took place
um
that you have various constituencies
people who might not even become
constituencies until they act in a
fairly shared way
constituencies reacting to this
particular killing
the initial reaction of course is on the
part of the police
and you have what we call the official
story you have george shippy standing up
um he's not actually in his bloody shirt
he changes it
and launders it for you conspiracy
theorists so there really is no bloody
shirt indicating that he'd been wounded
as badly as he claimed he had been
the police react initially and you have
a remarkable and disturbing
instance of police power being
i think we can say abused by the
standards of the time perhaps not there
weren't too many cries against it but
you had a number of people who proved
utterly innocent who were arrested and
sweated in fact a couple of them were
university of chicago students
who came in for a lot of suspicion as
anarchist liking immigrant liking people
i think that's a badge of honor for this
part of town
you had a police response you had
fairly quickly
the
left-wing response not just the
anarchists but the socialists who were
conscious of themselves as very
different groups still a few years
before the uh the bolshevik revolution
and still years before socialism
has
worldwide triumphs and worldwide centers
of influence that really
skew the conflict we needed it in
anarchy
um
left-wing people the left-wing groups
respond you have uh the daily socialist
of the time was it
a thoughtful and well-written
well-researched
newspaper that has a lot to say about
the case both editorially and in terms
of its reporting
you have
the jewish community
that responds in a couple of interesting
ways
on the one hand you have people who are
immediately offended
typically the
more recent immigrant compute community
themselves who recognize themselves as
subject to the same kinds of arbitrary
police power abuses
who are terrified that simply because
they're jewish and foreign
um they're in for some trouble
they want to see something happen
you also have as you have a split within
the chicago jewish community which is
mirrored in the american jewish
community at large
the more recent more recently arrived
eastern european immigrants and the
longer residing
german
jewish immigrants
again this being of the center the south
south shore area being the center of
the german jewish immigrant community no
longer immigrant at that point
those people came more slowly to
call for some kind of investigation
for of the of the affair
um but remarkably did come through and i
think it's a real tribute to those
people that they were able eventually
for the most part to say
this death does affect us and we are a
part of it but again this incident gives
us an opportunity to see the way the
jewish community of chicago responded to
this particular kind of crisis
you have as well another
group in all of this
the handful of people who actually knew
and cared about lazarus afriba
his one relative in the city was olga
his sister olga abraham
who was arrested by the police
sweated is the term and they used the
term in the newspaper so readily
just as we might say questioned by
police today
i don't i mean i i'm hoping that's what
they meant by it that they just
questioned her but i suspect it was
something more fearsome than that we do
know that they took her into a room
without preparing her didn't tell her
why she was arrested asked her what they
could took her into a room and showed
her on a body the body of her her dead
brother
that's how she found out they were
hoping to shock a confession out of her
they did the same with one of her best
friends who had lived with her for some
time who was for a while deemed
over box red queen or red mistress you
know there were lurid headlines that
came out of some of these things
um
this particular group again i want to go
back to that before i lose it all
together the image of the bagel the
story shaped like a babel bagel all of
these create all of these
constituencies responding to the same
incident and if not talking to each
other
then talking about the same thing at the
same time which i think is as close to a
cultural conversation as you're going to
find
and again one of the things that i hope
emerges in the book is just that it
brings that moment back makes clear not
just that there were hatreds or that
there was racism or anti-immigrant
feeling but a particular instance a
particular case where those become
especially clear
what olga averbach did after well she
was she was
locked up she had some
benefactors people who worked with her
in what this was not the myriam club
some immigrant jewish women not they i
keep saying immigrant it's on the tip of
my tongue some established german jewish
women who um had been working with the
young
ghetto women as sometimes what they call
them
the immigrant women to teach them about
citizenship to teach them uh various
skills
these women came to olga's assistance
and brought in a real heavyweight
brought the case to the attention of
jane adams
who constitutes a constituency all her
own
and got things done and what adam was
able to do uh in conjunction um we
believe with julius rosenwald um among
others one of the leading german jewish
in the city not if not all of chicago
able to raise something of a defense
fund which called for
hiring a court a new uh
hiring hiring out for a second coroner's
inquest
and also for hiring an attorney to
represent them and the case for seeking
an attorney was i mean the the business
of seeking attorney was interesting
they kept trying to find someone who
would take this case someone who would
represent the estate of lazarus auerbach
such as it was or the interests of
olga's
and they couldn't find anybody
john harlan was a leading attorney in
the city they were hoping to get him
he couldn't do it
um
others just said look
this will ruin my career so they found a
young man who had actually just gotten
out of law school i i wonder how
promising his career looked at the time
but it was harold ickes
and the very first case that harold
ickes who would go on to become the
secretary of
security the interior
under fdr
served as a senior member of the cabinet
for
11 years the first case he handled out
of law school was representing lazarus
averbach so i mentioned earlier that
some of the important data we had for
our research was
uh his papers that had that had been
sealed for 25 years after his death
um his son of course is
of this son of the same name is of
course
very active in the clinton
administration
i pause again i don't know if if i'm
leaving
uh i don't remember the
the forward that there was ladies jewish
lady who was connected with jane adams
center and she was the one who was
really instrumental in getting uh
uh the defense
uh in behalf of uh avrobac
and then they had it in the in the
american jewish history association in
the right-hand column in the and the in
the forward they wrote wrote her up and
then they mentioned they mentioned the
overbought case in that no okay
that she was in charge of
uh well probably they did i can't even
say if they did or didn't but i don't
remember her name i'm sorry to say but
there was a jewish lady who was
associated with jane adams yeah um
the name escapes me too um
was there but she was not one of the i
mean what the
what the what the um what the hull house
women often did was
um
a remarkable job of reaching out to lots
of different constituencies um i would
have been very surprised if in fact they
had mentioned the avarak affair only
because it's so utterly forgotten
so entirely forgotten
um
yeah but no thank you thank you for
mentioning that though because that that
the whole house was central to making
this into something that became a
controversy
um
one
resident of chicago made the comment in
one of the newspaper articles
he was a very foolish young man to go
there why was he foolish why uh
this when the individual who made that
statement looks like he he's washing his
hands of this was a case of murder cold
blooded murdered by the police chief
yeah it's funny when you start throwing
around a word like foolish it's hard to
know where it goes in some respects it
is foolish to go to a place where you
are so different and where you in some
ways do not belong on the other hand i
hope that i'm foolish if i say there are
places in chicago where you shouldn't be
able to go
but doesn't it remind you of a very
recent incident i forget where it was
but i was on some holiday and i was i
think
asians two asian guys come up to a house
to ask for directions where to go i
think it's in florida no louisiana
louisiana and they shoot them and and
they were actually there was a
it was halloween
and um it's you know it's like a couple
years ago
and they were found he was found not
guilty he was found it was self-defense
when in the trial so i mean
that happened two years ago it's a very
you know immigrants again
coming up to a house
being shot and
it's being found
without ever having heard of the case
you refer to i would say that yes this
reminds me of it um and yes it reminds
me of other
the other i want to ask you a little
about i was really shocked to hear about
the miriam club
the miriam club
was
actually my aunt ran that marion club
for many many years
if it's the one that we're talking about
it's a club that was in woodlawn
it was there was jewish orphan homes
to have um
a temple one always had
a place for
the elderly and one always had a place
for orphans so that in chicago there was
a jewish orphan homes and then when the
women
grew to an age where they were no longer
eligible to be in the working home
the myriam club which was german run by
or organized and funded by the german
jews of chicago
took in all of them and eventually what
happened was that women from you know
they went to the university of chicago
lived there so it became a very central
part of this part of the city so it
really connects hyde parks and us with
your story
in a very nice way
you're hesitant you're going to go on
with the story but
eventually did they ever charge does
their chief shipley with murder
no no no they did not
um
at the coroner's inquest they wanted to
determine what had happened and uh
they're interesting i i i can't share
all the details because it becomes a
fairly detailed story and i want to save
some for the book but
the um the autopsy the second autopsy is
the stuff of strange b movies
um among other things they found um that
the original the corner at the time was
a man named peter hoffman
share uh coroner peter half my mom said
sheriff peter hoffman because he's uh he
became better known later as the sheriff
um he was a noted uh
i i don't know that i do much of an
injustice if i say he was something of a
crooked sheriff
um his career coincided with uh much of
al capone's
uh campaign
um
but uh uh icke's has wonderful things to
say about him my blood boiled you know
it was it was going up against men like
fred bussey the mayor and um and and
peter hoffman the coroner that sharpened
my teeth for doing battle with
um with hitler and hirohito and
he just you know he thought these people
were as loathsome as as one could one
could get
the second autopsy revealed that
hoffman's original autopsy had
overlooked an additional bullet wound
which is pretty serious a fatal bullet
not detected but more than that and more
bizarre than that um the original
autopsy had
checked averbach's brain for
abnormalities to see if perhaps
as you can imagine it looked like an
anarchist brain whatever an anarchist's
brain would look like
when they buried the body
they forgot to put the brain back in
and you have this bizarre case and ickes
talks about using this privately as
blackmail saying
you realize if you if it comes out to
the orthodox jewish community within
which the the body is
the the
is not to be
uh tampered with if it comes out that
you buried this body without a brain
you'll never get reelected again
icky's claims that he used that to uh to
keep um
hoffman from bringing up the case of
anarchy from ringing up the charge of
anarchy so according to the ickes he won
in that although he never defended he
never was turned around to attack shippy
he claims officially and in fact what
little official documentation there is
says nothing about anarchy
so at least in that regard icky's icky's
feels that he won
if i written the book in the beginning
correctly he had a gun
right what was he doing with a gun well
you're right if he walks in with a gun
and a knife if in fact he does then it's
a little hard to defend him
as having been an anarchist it's
possible he simply had it but
the only testimony we have well we have
testimony from the shippy family
themselves that he had a gun and a knife
very large knife very large gun but the
testimony at the same time from his
sister is that
he did not have a knife or a gun and b
he didn't have enough money to purchase
either one of them and if he had no
connection to anarchist groups he
couldn't have acquired them
uh he
they did the police did uncover a uh a
pawn broker who said he had had sold the
the weapons
but it's interesting pawn brokers at the
time were
relied on on the good graces of the
police to stay in business
and so it's testimony that comes under a
lot of criticism even then even in the
press it's a very dubious
um basis for this but yes if he did have
a knife and that that becomes a part of
the question whether in fact he had a
knife or a gun
um
one uh i don't know one last thing i
would want to pass along and then take
whatever additional questions you might
have is the question that we get
occasionally um about why this why no
one remembers this story
um i i know that i assume i'm talking to
a lot of people who are dedicated
chicago files um who you know who who
can nod when i say fred bussey and go oh
yeah he was
it's a good thing we got rid of fred
bussey or
peter hoffman
um but
almost no one we've run into has heard
of averbach and almost no one writes
about averbach
except for an article
about 20 years ago
in midstream
there might not be anything that has
been written explicitly and exclusively
on averbach since
1908 1909 even since it happened itself
almost completely forgotten
when the story is remembered it's
remembered in footnotes um as there were
a series of anarchist assassination
attempts in 1908. uh this followed on
the heels of one in a month earlier in
denver a man named giuseppe alia
killed the
killed a priest in in denver
and then almost a month later exactly
a man in new york
silverstein i believe is his name um set
off a bomb attempted to set up a bomb
actually managed only to kill himself
um but in both of those cases you had
people who were these were crimes that
clearly fit an anarchist crime pattern
they were there were notes saying this
is why i am doing this an anarchist
crime makes very little sense if it's a
political crime and it's a symbolic
crime it makes very little sense to
to perpetrate it without giving some
message
um
so you have it remembered as part of a
wave of these things
but other than that it's almost
forgotten unless it comes up in stories
biographies of emma goldman or ben
reitman or jane adams
or
heraldickis
so that's where it floats around
my own theory at walters
walters theory is that it's
it's not pleasant to remember unpleasant
things and i think there's a lot to that
um it is the the yiddish word is a
shanda something that we're ashamed of
and want to forget and want to make as
if it had not happened i think that's
certainly
important part of why we've forgotten
this but i i think as well um
i'm sorry i'm sorry for many reasons
that walter isn't here but i'm sorry
that it's it's my last word rather than
his um but i think that one reason this
story is so broadly forgotten is because
it simply doesn't fit
what
an easy history would be
i call it shape i say as i say it's
shaped like a donut but
um it's neither
it's not exactly a case of an anarchist
assassination attempt if it were it'd be
easy to recall it it's not exactly a
case of police brutality
it's not exactly a case of civil rights
being
trampled upon
it's not exactly
a case of
chicago's jewish community coming
together around a central cause it's all
of those things and yet not quite any of
them
and so
i mean i i apologize for taking
so long in a sense to tell the story all
the way through but i think that's how
long it takes so i think one reason
we've forgotten it is because unless we
tell it all
it stops making sense
so
um
i invite any any questions any further
questions
did he's ever respond to olga's letter
the last letter that you have in here to
him about you know clearing her
brother's name not that we know of not
that we know of um that letter gets uh
this is a reference to a letter that
we've included in an appendix um
um it's a you you ask about i i hope
that you found it a rather moving letter
uh and uh just the the
yeah i mean sort of the the power of
testimonial of a woman who says you know
i i'm really betrayed by the american
system betrayed by the american dream
we had hoped we'd be able to find more
information about the averbach family
this is the last information that we
have that olga wrote from
i think she was back in in sharanowitz
wrote to
jane adams
to ickes saying please do what you can
to clear my brother's name please
remember who i am
uh who he was do what you can
um
and we we don't know anything more about
her and it's
not hard to imagine that somebody who
would uh a jewish woman who would go
back to europe at that time who would
probably be disinclined to leave anytime
soon probably was killed during world
war ii but we haven't been able to
confirm that
it seems to me that the the uh police
skivvy or chevy
i can't it's hard to believe that he was
not held culpable for this murder
it it is hard to believe and yet
what what's fascinating about it and and
the no it sounds like today
well the the interesting revenge is that
shippy is actually never again
acting chief of police
he he's officially the chief for another
few months at which point he um
he they
he steps down or he resigns retires he's
he's in a uh
a sanitarium for what they call
softening of the brain
um most likely a result of an advanced
case of syphilis frankly
uh that doesn't seem too much larger
leap to make and most likely
conjuring up all kinds of questions
about you know how a supposed upholder
of the law would have
um
acquired such a disease uh and he's
replaced before long he's dead within a
couple of years he doesn't really
outlive it as is his son
of a burst attendant appendix and his
his daughter and wife
who her name is he's got a daughter
named georgina and a niece named
georgetta or i've got that reversed
perhaps but
i've always kind of imagined the kind of
ego dimensions of a man who would govern
his family like that
his wife and daughter are not buried
with him they're just gone and his you
know in some ways his story ends almost
maybe at that same moment
as our box he just doesn't know it for a
year or two
lazarus auerbach
is he buried in the in in waltham what
is it to a cemetery out here um or
someplace
or is it the one over on clark street
and and and irving park uh no it's not
it's not clark and irving um
i
i would have to check with walter to be
certain of the exact spot um but even of
whether it's marked walter did walter
did most of the work on that he was here
um one one would hope but uh it's you
know this he's he's forgotten in a lot
of ways
i think it was murder it was i was
murdered by a a high person like a chief
eric and he could do that
but went this foreigner coming to him to
you know why did he come to my house you
know attacked me you know you killed him
well you you've had you've had my you've
had sort of my spin on this in as much
as i said i want this i'm hoping i can
present a dialogue walter's not here and
i miss him and i i assure you that
you've missed a lot in not having been
able to hear his him put forward his
story first person
i'm going to emphasize as i as i talk
about the the bigger forces at play but
walter sees this in a lot of ways as a
as a mystery a murder mystery and i i
hope that that part of this story comes
through too um what happened was it
murder was it not and one of the things
that's been it's been my real pleasure
to speak with you tonight and it's been
a pleasure to speak with um
friends and other people who've had a
chance to read it and just to hear you
know was it murder uh was it an accident
so
um
let me say thank you very much to to all
of you and to 57th street
i'd be happy to answer any of the
questions informally
emma goldman um
where do you have evidence of her
relationship with mr reitman oh it's
extensive it's wonderful yeah in in
living
she's not shy in living my life
um which is her autobiography she goes
on and on and great stories about you
know some great line about uh as shutler
was looking for me little did he suspect
i was you know
you know i was in the arms of my lover
and and sort of great details about
misunderstandings and uh where was she
born
was she born in europe or she was born
in europe
she had the
good fortune for political reasons to
come here and marry at a young age
and apparently never officially divorced
so she was a u.s citizen and secured
from you know deportation
you don't know what country in europe
was romania russia poland
wasn't she deported back to russia in
1935 and then they supported her from
russia but the book doesn't say where
she was eventually she did go back i
don't know that she was deported as much
as she chose to leave but
you know whether she was quitter or
whether you whether you quit your job or
get fired i think that the point
eventually becomes moot yeah she was
um she wasn't welcome here but
to her credit she was in those days so
many labor movements and even among the
jews to arbiter ring the workman circle
and so many other
you know these people were on a suspect
of you know being anarchist because
you're in the labor you're sure
sure
how difficult was it to remain objective
when you were writing this story
did you ever find yourself rewriting
passages or um yeah there in fact their
passages i go back through and i look
and i go oh you know i should have been
a lot cooler there
you know
um at one uh we talk at one point uh
there's a
uh we have some testimony from congress
because this was a case that made it to
congress and we it comes right out of
the congressional record
and um
uh you have a congressman from i think
it's virginia who says something about
on the order of
uh that uh
um we were a fine country uh so long as
we limited ourselves to western or
northern europeans but ever ever since
we got eastern and southern europeans
it's we've gone downhill
and i i look back at sort of the way i
you know the way we handle that and the
voice i think at this point it's my
voice and i feel very i feel very
adolescent as i look back at it
saying can you believe a congressman
said that
and i feel very naive in retrospect
because unfortunately i can i can
readily believe a congressman saying
that certainly in 1908 and
um i think accomplishment
was the
immigration they limited
from eastern southern europe you know
the limited limit coming in for
individuals yeah yeah um
very important uh
thank you
it's very important uh to note that this
is the time when you first see
um serious efforts to limit immigration
to america and uh country
the the actual country of origin quota
system doesn't come into effect until
after world war one
twenty twenty twenty one twenty four
there's a series of increasingly
restrictive acts but uh eventually
um this kind of thing whether it
actually whether it was an anarchist
attempt or not
is the kind of thing that feeds into a
grand public sense that whoa these
people are dangerous and scary and let's
keep them out
and by cutting off immigration they
trapped six million jews in europe and
there was pogroms there that but that
was the original burst to get out of
europe then later on hitler you know
they were trapped
that yeah about immigration uh still
prevails somewhat today
i i i do unfortunately i think that uh
you know the immigrant looks a little
different now like now of course um i
mean i i speak i speak as someone who's
uh whose own grandparents came to
chicago roughly at the same time um own
jewish grandparents and now of course
you know i
you know
funny you don't look foreign i mean i i
our standards of what is american do do
change but i think unfortunately we
we keep on one side there's a there's a
barrier that the other side of which
people are are quote-unquote not
american
chairman a lot of people are talk
against having
any nationality not just jews
yeah i do i meant to i didn't mean to
say
i think the people we tend to uh um
make into the boogie figure now are
more often um uh
often often spanish-speaking peoples
um people who are darker-skinned
yeah that's i mean that's how we would
want to see it's much easier to see them
of course as wet backs rather than as
people i'm just as much easier to see
them as anarchists
but they're americans
i was amazed by how similar it was to
right after the bombing of the murrow
building
you know the because at first they
thought it was middle eastern terrorists
that had bombed that and it was the same
hysteria
as
i mean it sounded
like you could have
just changed the
that where it was set and the
nationality and the hysteria and the
newspapers and the press and people was
identical to what happened in chicago
yeah i mean i i think you're absolutely
right
um
thank you for such a warm reception
i
thank you
hi
nice to see you
thanks for coming
um
nice to meet you